da dove possa iniziare il problema non
sei tu ma sono io e solo io perché ho
tantissimi problemi e tu lo sai
però il problema vero e proprio più
grande per me sei proprio tu e quindi io
sono quella dei due chi ha più problemi
per questo motivo sono io il problema no
ma io non ce la faccio più cioè se
soffocante invade i miei spazi
o come uno spazio vitale ma cosa centro
che viviamo in due paesi diversi ma tu
hai idea di quanto spazio occupino i
tuoi messaggi nel mio telefono ma lo
siamo 2 giga in un mese mi sembra un po
tu maggio certo per me sei fantastico
però penso di aver bisogno di qualcuno
di più maturo al mio fianco
capisci quello che intendono d'accordo
la pena guardare gomma si muove guarda
nella mia vita non ho mai conosciuto
nessuno come te sei un uomo meraviglioso
dalle mille risorse e sei veramente
bello bellissimo dentro ecco il problema
è fuori perché non ci ho provato non
riesco proprio cioè non mi piace vi fa
il ribrezzo mi viene da vomitare quando
sono vicino a te la guerra fosse per me
non ti lascerai mai però non piace il
mio gatto sai per me verrà sempre prima
lui e che non periodo della mia vita in
cui ho proprio bisogno di stare sola
capisce dai ti prego non fare così torna
qui
senti io stasera sono a casa da sola è
come 6 soffre la solitudine
poi mi chiedevo ma se io e te
guardassimo un film oppure una serie che
poi possiamo anche interrompe insomma lo
sai iniziale casa mia è vero
che io sono un disastro cioè sono troppo
complicata come donna non riuscirai mai
a capirmi veramente lo vedi ti dico che
non riuscirai mai capi metrici che mi
capisce già cioè non andiamo d'accordo
sono troppo complicato per te ti ricordi
quella volta al supermercato c'è una
bellissima ragazza bionda con due bocce
così ecco il problema e lei no ma non
sono mai stata gelosa ma che me frega se
lavora col culo non è quello il punto
il problema è lei perché io l'amo perché
siamo una coppia perché stiamo insieme
perché vogliamo sposarci perché vogliamo
una famiglia insieme capisci cioè è per
questo che adesso lasciando capito cioè
tipo a te non piace il verde che il mio
colore preferito
mia mamma cucina e lasagne sul piatto
forte a te non piace la faccia su tante
cose che capito alla lunga io credo che
sia la scelta migliore per entrambi
dividerci c'è sicuramente la scelta
migliore per me perché non dovrei
piangere tempo che aspetto questo
momento che se non solo lacrime di
dolore
no queste sono lacrime di gioia tutti tu
ti devo l'ora di da sorte ma svolge il
giorno più bello della mia vita amore
ciao tesoro ruolo